Bobby Fischer had a column in a magazine
called boy's life okay so has basically
Boy Scouts of America and I didn't
realize that but basically in the entire
60s the United States Chess Federation
was trying to get the Boy Scouts of
America to do a merit badge and he get
chess recognized in the whole system
millions of young American boys and
young American girls for the Girl Scouts
of America were involved in those
programs and we couldn't get chess
involved then we had what can only be
described as this thing felt effect and
Jeannie Jeannie Cink Phil said well
actually I have a best friend who's on
the committee for the merit badges I
think I can get chess merit badge
credential and she did it she had a
breakthrough that I am Telling You at
least 20 years at least what am I saying
20 years 40 years
Bernie's that chess couldn't make that
breakthrough and thanks to Jeannie's
efforts it did and this is so important
to the growth of American chess and US
chasis this marriage between dr. Judy
sings feels lifelong kind of commitment
to the the scouts as well as of course
the founding of the saint was chess club
that she did with her her husband rats
exactly and I really feel like that was
an important moment in the history of
the st. Louis chess club because with
Jeannie getting more involved a lot of
things change we also had the music
music series at the world chess Hall of
Fame started the result these kind of
saw this kind of synergy between music
scouting chess kids and of course that
was the goal of the Chess Club from the
very beginning but really getting GD
more involved we saw more and more
events dedicated to that now about five
years later we have the Karen's Cup
which is a corollary to the incredible
Sinquefield Cop featuring ten of the top
women players in the world this but it
kind of goes back and forth so the the
point was the same fields decided to
retire
and honey where do you want to retire
well we always like st. Louis let's move
over there and okay so what are you
gonna do
and Rex says well I love chess I'm gonna
go off and do chess and the genie says
well I love music I'm gonna go off and
do music and okay you do your thing I'll
do my thing and then it was like genie
kind of looked over and said well the
chess is actually very interesting we
can combine some music performances as
well and oh but I really like the
scouting Scouts as well does genie and
we can combine that with chess and the
next thing you know is like we're
pulling Gd you know away from her really
music inclined nests and in the chess
and the next thing you know she's she's
figuring out she's the scientist in the
in the family she's figuring out our
tiebreaks
and everything for the Grantchester
horror that's right I mean that's the
thing about chest you can combine it
with any passion because it's this it's
this great canvas and we should mention
that the Karin's cup is is named because
karen says genie it's maybe maiden name
right so this is the first year they
Karen's company I don't believe it's
gonna be the last well we were following
on the success of the sink oh yeah okay
so when you think about the Piatigorsky
and you think about these great
historical chess tournaments the sink
fell Cup suddenly bang instantly became
an instant classic and this great great
tournament you have world
Magnus win it and then but slightly
became the world champion and then
Fabiano have the best tournament
performance in history
exactly I felt like it was history
within two years I know it is crazy
right an instant history - and so the
sink filled cup suddenly becomes this
fixture on the calendar annually for the
greatest players in the world and then
you know like we're kind of ribbing a
genie a little bit and saying GE about a
lady's cup that features the best women
around the world and sticking that on
the calendar and you know see how how
the ladies would do because recently it
was the most recent Sinquefield Cup we
had so many drawers right how
competitively inclined are the ladies
going to be will
they draw that many games the other nice
thing about this event is that the
fortuitous timing of it we've got the
first time that we have an international
toward a bit of this level for women in
st. Louis and rights capital chess in
America we also have this week on
February 1st 2019 girls became eligible
for scouting badges so technically this
is like actually we had an event today
where we had girls come out to get their
chess merit badge arena the first
opportunity ever for girls to get this
badge Wow
so just days before we open the Karen's
Cup right we have girls entering the
fray in scouting and one of the nice
things about the merit badge is it's not
just about learning chess and becoming a
great chess player I actually gave a
lecture to the girls and what I love
about the badge is it's also about
teaching a French ass that's one of the
things you need to do exactly order to
get the bat right to show like
communities yeah yeah it's not like you
could just become good and learn the
moves and pass the test you've got to do
help somebody else learn the moves and
pass the tests as well exactly and
that's one thing a lot of times are
especially when you're teaching
beginners or intermediate players what
you notice is that there's a lot of
differing levels so oftentimes you
almost have to go in and have the
advanced person or the advanced girls
and say like hey like when you're done
solving the problem you know help your
friend help this person understand what
you understand exactly and I saw some of
the girls doing that and to me that's
the greatest honor that when you're
teaching and you see people giving it
back to other right you can pass it down
the line yeah and that's what I love
about this concept of the scouting badge
that we have so many initiatives in us
chests that are about getting the best
players we can and we're doing really
well with that but just the idea of
outreach and chess being a game for the
community this is really really
beautiful and I love to see it happen
one of the things that was really
shocking for me in 2016 I became the
girls they dragged I became the women's
team captain for the Olympia
okay and that was the first time really
I got a chance to sit down with all of
our ladies we were having meals together
and really talking to them about the
careers and one of the things that was
really shocking to me is how few
opportunities that they had to play in
what we would call profitable events
okay
so women are always playing in these
opens and really risking you know their
travel hotel money and all of their
costs no guarantees of victory of a
profitable outcome and the Karan's Cup
however is going to give an opportunity
for the women that's a guaranteed
profitable experience it's really
important there's $150,000 prize fun and
I can't you can't overstate what you're
saying that it's so important for women
to UM have competitive prize funds and
expenses paid for remember exactly a lot
like some of these women are moms
precisely and if they're not moms they
might they might be considering starting
family and as we know in society there's
a wealth gap and a wage gap and women
are expected to do more of the childcare
right so if they're not getting paid
it's just gonna be hard for them to sway
and not only that if you have for
example in the case of a Varina crush
somebody who is really out there being a
chess teacher then and she's got a
guaranteed income doing what she does
then if she's going to take two weeks
off to play in a tournament an open
event she's gotta weigh that against the
potential wins versus guaranteed lost
income and for the Karen's Cup what
really excites me as well that you
mentioned in American players is that
Americans watching the broadcast and you
know following the event can say hey
maybe I can make this tournament one day
right it's a dream you're building a
dream because it's not just prize money
it's also a wonderful conditions and
getting to play in this beautiful chess
capital and I know that when I was
growing up when I saw the tournament
really well run in a beautiful location
it became part of a fantasy like maybe I
can play for that money one day and
on the great stage sacrificing my queen
right and inspiring speaking of which -
by the way one of the really cool things
about this event well I'm a sexist I I
love women
how many commentators we have female
chess commentators we're going to have
in Russian Tonya and alive oh but Amira
will be doing with your scripts and -
and Karlovich yes ourselves so I mean
it's great to be a part of it that's
right well you know within we we can't
really have total popularity of chess
and so we get more women involved right
totally agreed and right now in u.s.
chess is getting a little bit better I
know what the statistics now are like
fifteen percent participation by women
and a lot of that is girls so the girl
level it might be closer to 20 25
percent but we got to get closer to
fifty percent if we don't seem to be as
popular as it can be
no question